the only wire has this report Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model Chrissy
Teigen responded to the backlash against
her as she dared critics to do your
worst after she recently announced that
her miscarriage was actually in abortion
the 36 year old hit back at negative
comments that started flooding the
official Instagram account of Glamor a
magazine that published Tegan's account
or comments rather about the death of
her 20 week old unborn child named Jack
Teagan took a screenshot of many of the
responses with some calling her a drama
queen and a liar and others accusing her
of trying to stay relevant
she then tweeted the message that read I
knew this would happen and honestly I've
already seen you do your worst so if
this makes you feel better great it
doesn't make me feel worse though the
backlash comes following Tegan's
comments at the proper dailies a day of
unreasonable conversation Summit where
she labeled her miscarriage in 2020 in
abortion
um Tegan shared quite quote two years
ago when I was pregnant with Jack John
and my third child I had to make a lot
of difficult and heartbreaking decisions
when I was pregnant with Jack John and
my third child
pregnant with I don't understand that it
became very clear about halfway through
that he would not survive and that I
wouldn't that I wouldn't either without
any medical intervention let's just call
it what it was it was an abortion
abortion to save my life for a baby that
has absolutely no chance and to be
honest I never ever put that together
until actually a few months ago I told
the world we had a miscarriage the world
agree with a miscarriage all the
headlines said it was a miscarriage and
I became really frustrated that I didn't
in the first place say it was what it
was and I felt silly that it had taken
me over a year to actually understand
that we had an abortion so this is a
bizarre story in many ways and let me
just say to begin with that
um
you know you get this from uh
celebrities all the time especially from
Chrissy from from Chrissy Teigen she's
she kind of specializes in this where
she'll
they'll announce something personal
about their lives that nobody asked them
to announce they didn't have to say it
um but they tell the world
and then people have opinions about it
and they get offended and they play the
victim the thing is once you have
presented something to the world
information you didn't have to present
once you've done that then people are
going to have opinions because people
have opinions about everything any any
piece of information someone comes
across they form they have a perspective
that they bring to it and they're going
to have their own perspective
and so if you don't want anyone's
perspective on a personal detail about
your life
don't tell anybody
and that's even more the case when
you're using
a something from your life and you're
injecting it into the to a to a a
contentious subject like abortion so you
are drawing this connection you're
bringing this up to the public
and then you play the victim and also
the hero do your worst everyone making
it's like what do you think was gonna
happen well you knew that was gonna
happen
and it also it doesn't make any sense
now I don't know
I don't know exactly what happened with
uh this this pregnancy and how it ended
I don't know I wasn't there
what I do know though is as she admits
as she acknowledges she announced that
it was a miscarriage and she even if I
remember correctly
there were pictures that that she took
of her cradling her child who was
deceased in her arms and uh she posted
the pictures and said we had a
miscarriage it's a terrible thing and it
is a terrible thing you know we've been
through this in my family and it's awful
so that's what we know
and now she says well I I didn't realize
at the time that it was an abortion well
what
how could you not realize something was
an abortion if that's what it was
because
well an abortion is the intentional
direct destruction of the child it's
like you go in and kill the child that's
what an abortion is
and also I've never heard of an abortion
but now let's get now we get very grim
and dark when thinking about this but
have you ever heard of an abortion where
they they kill the child and then
give the child's dead body to you to
take pictures with that that doesn't
happen in an abortion clinic
um so none of this makes sense and
certainly if
if you had the child directly killed
through abortion you would know it
there's no looking back on it two years
later and saying oh you know what maybe
that was an abortion there's there's no
confusion about what's happening
so it seems to me
what has happened here if I'm to make
sense of this and again I I you know we
all are within our rights to try to make
sense of it she's the one who's
presented this to the world she didn't
happen when she did so
it seems to me what's happened
is that
there was a terrible Health complication
with the child
they had to deliver the child
early uh too early for the child to
survive and so and and he died
tragically
um it seems like that's what happened
and that also explains how she we had
the pictures of her holding the child
but that's not an abortion though see
this is the point
that is not an abortion
I mean there there are times that we've
always acknowledged this there are times
when there could be a a medical crisis
in the in the middle of a pregnancy
something that affects the child or the
mother and uh it becomes clear that the
pregnancy cannot continue the pregnancy
has to be ended in order to preserve the
life of the mother that can certainly
happen it's not common it's rare but it
does happen
well if you end the pregnancy
by delivering the child without first
killing the child intentionally that's a
delivery that is not an abortion an
abortion by definition is the direct
intentional
physical killing of the child if that
does not happen then there was no
abortion
and if you have to deliver a child early
to preserve the life of the mother
knowing almost certainly that the child
will not be able to survive being
delivered that early that's still not an
abortion
that's the principle of double effect
that is you know you're you're you're
you're you're you're you're taking an
action you're delivering the child not
intending at all to kill the child but
yet that that ends up being a result of
that action but that's not your
intentions not why you're doing it
you're doing it for a good reason to
preserve the mother's life
so it's an act of preservation
it's not murder
so that is what would make sense of this
to me but then so why are you coming
back two years later and saying you know
what I'm counting that as an abortion
it would really seem like you're using
this terrible tragedy that happened to
you and your child
to make a political point
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts